a diciembre de 2019 gran parte del mundo
festeja la llegada de un nuevo año
[Aplausos]
[Música]
mientras el mundo celebra esta ciudad en
el centro de china comienza a preocupar
a la comunidad científica e
internacional
los hospitales dibujan empiezan a
recibir decenas de casos de un tipo de
neumonía extraña para los médicos
los primeros contagios son reportados a
la oms y las autoridades sanitarias de
china cierran el mercado mayorista de
mariscos después de que se descubriera
que los animales salvajes vendidos allí
pueden ser la fuente del virus
[Música]
a varios análisis china comunica que los
casos desconocidos de neumonía enojan no
son provocados por los virus del sars ni
del merz sino por uno nuevo de la
familia de los corona virus llamado en
un principio por la o ms 2019 n com
el 11 de enero la comisión de salud
municipal de luján reporta la primera
muerte provocada por este coronavirus un
hombre de 61 años que había estado en el
mercado de mariscos pronto la comunidad
internacional empieza a girar su
atención hacia esta ciudad de 11
millones de habitantes
entiendo que las autoridades de china
continental que lidian con esta
enfermedad están en contacto con la
organización mundial de la salud así que
estoy segura de que continuarán haciendo
si este es un nuevo coronavirus y las
secuencias se han puesto a disposición
del público en plataformas en línea que
son accesibles para todos agua sarakhs
hasta dos días después de la primera
muerte las autoridades de tailandia y
japón reportan los primeros casos fuera
de china
[Música]
i
un nuevo reto para las autoridades
comienza la migración humana más grande
del mundo el año nuevo lunar chino
[Música]
pese a que los casos se multiplican
millones de ciudadanos viajan a sus
ciudades de origen
[Música]
el 21 de enero el virus cruza el océano
pacifico funcionarios en el estado de
washington confirman el primer caso en
eeuu un hombre de 30 años cerca de
desear
la buena noticia es que los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades y
nosotros estamos de acuerdo en que el
riesgo es bajo para los residentes del
estado de washington
tras este anuncio las alarmas se prenden
en el mundo y los aeropuertos comienzan
a tomar medidas
[Música]
rujana anuncia que cerrará temporalmente
sus aeropuertos y estaciones de
ferrocarril tras las noticias de que el
número de muertos ha aumentado a 17 las
autoridades de china confirman al menos
547 casos
ah
pese a las restricciones globales el
virus aterriza en europa
el caso que fue hospitalizado en burdeos
y circuló en redes sociales es un caso
positivo confirmado de coronavirus el
paciente tiene 48 años acaba de regresar
de china donde pasó pocos días y estuvo
en la ciudad de wuhan el número de casos
globales continúa creciendo para el 25
de enero la cifra ya es de más de 1000
positivos y para el 27 el número de
muertos es de más de 100 ante el
incremento acelerado de casos rusia toma
medidas drásticas para frenar el avance
del virus
hoy le informamos a todos sobre las
medidas tomadas para cerrar la frontera
con china en el lejano esto extender
junio 30 días después de que comenzara
la crisis la organización mundial de la
salud hace un importante anuncio
handy clearing public health sin madre
claro una emergencia de salud pública de
preocupación internacional por el brote
mundial del nuevo corona virus del colon
haber coronado a eros
mientras el mundo supera las 500 muertes
dos escenas de películas acuden al mundo
el crucero diamond princess que
transportaba a más de 3.700 personas es
puesto en cuarentena
y en la ciudad de epicentro del virus
hand se termina de construir un hospital
con capacidad para mil pacientes
fabricados en sólo 10 días
el 7 de febrero ligua el yang un médico
dibujan que fue blanco de la policía por
intentar alertar sobre el virus muere
contagiado
[Música]
pese a las disputas comerciales entre
eeuu y china el presidente trump elogia
la labor de beijing en el manejo de la
crisis
[Música]
anoche tuve una muy buena charla con el
presidente chip y hablamos
principalmente sobre el coronavirus
están trabajando muy duro y creo que
están haciendo un trabajo muy
profesional
el 10 de febrero pese a que el
coronavirus ha cobrado la vida de más de
1000 personas en todo el mundo
el presidente de trump sorprende con una
polémica posición frente al virus
ahora el virus del que estamos hablando
sabes mucha gente piensa que
desaparecerá en abril con el calor
el 11 de febrero el director general de
la o ms nombra por primera vez una
palabra que se repetiría millones de
veces
winamp en name por ahora tenemos un
nombre para la enfermedad y es hobbit 19
hold it nine en un turista chino que fue
diagnosticado con el virus muere en
francia convirtiéndose en la primera
persona en fallecer por el brote en
europa
la cifra de muertos por el coronavirus
asciende a más de 1500 y las autoridades
de egipto reportan un caso confirmando
así el primer positivo de áfrica
la segunda semana de febrero un rayo de
esperanza empieza a verse en china los
casos comienzan a disminuir y la crisis
parece haber terminado
[Música]